This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. On the last episode, I promise you the greatest podcast crossover event in history. And here it is. From Gimlett, this is reply-all. I'm Alex Goldman. And I'm PJ Vot. And this week PJ, we have a Super Tech Support. A Super Tech Support is a segment on our show where listeners come to us with their weird, unsolvable tech problems. And one of us usually you goes out and tries to solve it for them. Mm-hmm.
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在上期节目中，我向大家保证了历史上最棒的播客联动活动。它来了。来自吉姆莱特工作室，这是“回复全员”。我是亚历克斯·戈尔曼。我是P·J·沃特。本周，P·J，我们有一个超级技术支持。超级技术支持是我们节目中的一个环节，听众带着他们奇怪、无法解决的技术问题来找我们。我们中的一个人——通常是你——会去找他们并试图解决问题。嗯。
And you have one. I do. Tell me about it. So we got an email from a guy named Ben. He lives in Houston. And Ben is a huge fan of podcasts. He has his own podcast. He said he listens to over 100 podcasts, which like,
而且你有一个。我确实有。跟我说说。所以我们收到了一位名叫本的听众的电子邮件。他住在休斯顿。本是个坚定的播客迷。他有自己的播客。他说他听了超过100个播客，就像是，
I don't even know how that's possible. He said that though one complaint he has about his podcast app is that it tallies how much time he spends listening to podcasts. It tells me how many overall days of podcasts I've listened to and it's just more and more depressing. You know, would you like to guess? Sure, yes. All right, 40 days. 133.
我甚至不知道这怎么可能。不过他说，他对他使用的播客应用程序的一个抱怨是，它会统计他花在听播客上的时间。它告诉我，我总共听了多少天的播客，这只会让人越来越沮丧。你知道，你想猜猜吗？当然，好啊。好吧，40天。133天。
Oh my god. And recently he started having this very strange podcast-related problem, which is what? he started having this very strange podcast related problem, which is what. So Ben, not too long ago, got a new car. It was a 2016 Mazda 6. And the thing that he was most excited about in his new car was that he could pair his phone using Bluetooth so that he could listen to podcasts. Oh, before he was like an oxen guy.
哦，天哪。最近他开始遇到这个非常奇怪的、与播客相关的问题，是什么问题呢？他开始遇到这个非常奇怪的与播客相关的问题，是什么。所以本不久前买了一辆新车。那是一辆2016款马自达6。他的新车最让他兴奋的事情是，他可以通过蓝牙连接手机，这样他就可以听播客了。哦，在此之前他好像是个用音频线的人。
Yes. Anyway, for some reason, the radio in his new car refuses to play one podcast and one podcast only, which is the radio to be a podcast 99% visible. Really? Yes. And it's driving him absolutely insane. His car Bluetooth has rejected Roman Mars and his stories. Yes. Obviously, like for people who don't know, 90% visible, host rejected Roman Mars in his stories.
是的。无论如何，由于某种原因，他新车上的收音机拒绝播放一个播客，而且仅仅是一个播客，那就是那个广播播客《99%隐形》。真的吗？是的。这让他完全快要疯了。他的车载蓝牙拒绝了罗曼·马尔斯和他的故事。是的。显然，对于不了解的人来说，《90%隐形》的主持人拒绝了罗曼·马尔斯和他的故事。
Yes, obviously for people who don't know, 9% visible, host to better Roman Mars. It's this really great non-fiction podcast. They tell all these stories about design, like how things work in the world and why they're made the way they're made, like the stories behind those things. And apparently it is the one podcast
是的，显然对于不了解的人来说，《9%隐形》的主持人更像是罗曼·马尔斯。这是一个非常棒的非小说类播客。他们讲述了所有关于设计的故事，比如世界上事物是如何运作的，以及它们为什么会被制成现在的样子，比如这些事物背后的故事。显然这是唯一的播客
that doesn't work on his car. That's right. So I asked Ben to play 99% visible through his car stereo while he was on the phone with me. Can you tell me exactly where you're sitting at the moment? Alright, I'm sitting at my driver's seat in my 2016 Mazda 6. Okay. Um, and... Let me know when you press play.
在他的车上无法播放。没错。所以我让本在跟我通话时通过他的车载音响播放《99%隐形》。你能告诉我你此刻正坐在哪里吗？好吧，我正坐在2016款马自达6的驾驶座上。好的。呃，然后……当你按下播放键时告诉我。
Alright, so... I'm gonna press play right now. This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The show does start playing, but like the display screen stops working, it totally freezes, the buttons aren't working properly. He has no control, it's just for playing on his own.
好吧，所以……我现在要按下播放键。这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。节目确实开始播放了，但显示屏停止工作了，完全死机了，按钮也无法正常工作。他失去了控制，这只是为了在他自己的车上播放。
A little of all of ours. The whole of oner is displayed. So he can't interact with the screen at all. It still says whatever I played right before 99% invisible. And then after about a minute, the screen just went blind. And now it's cut off and restarted. And I'm not playing 99% invisible anymore because every time I've done that, if it's still playing, it will freeze again. How could you have a tight problem where the trigger was like content?
有点像我们所有人的。整个所有者都在显示。所以他根本无法与屏幕互动。它仍然显示我在播放《99%隐形》之前播放的内容。然后大约一分钟后，屏幕变黑了。现在它中断并重新启动了。我不再播放《99%隐形》了，因为每次我这样做，如果它还在播放，它就会再次死机。你怎么会遇到一个触发条件是内容的讨厌问题呢？
I know, it's weird, right? It's very weird. It's like, it would make more sense to me if like, it broke down anytime you tried to listen like, podcasts that weren't, if it didn't work for car talk. I'd be like, okay, maybe his car doesn't want to hear stories about sick cars.
我知道，这很奇怪，对吧？非常奇怪。就像，如果它在尝试收听类似播客但不是的时候崩溃，或者如果不适用于汽车谈话节目，对我来说会更有意义。我会觉得，好吧，也许他的车不想听关于坏车的故事。
Maybe that's like upsetting or something like that. I really like that you've immediately gone be like, okay, maybe his car doesn't want to hear stories about sick cars. Maybe that's like upsetting or something like that. I really like that you've immediately gone to like the cars with chief sedges. Do you have any theories about what's going on? I don't know. My best guess is that because I looked at the file sizes and I listen to things like hardcore history and blank check which have big file sizes. And it's not that, my best guess is maybe he's using some sort of weird audio codec that interact strangely with my system, but I really couldn't tell you.
也许这让人心烦意乱什么的。我真的很喜欢你马上就联想到像汽车有情绪这种事。你对发生的事情有什么理论吗？我不知道。我最好的猜测是，因为我看过文件大小，而且我听过像《硬核历史》和《空白支票》这样文件很大的节目。不是这样的，我最好的猜测是也许他正在使用某种奇怪的音频编解码器，与我的系统产生奇怪的交互，但我真的说不准。
So I don't know. Ben thinks that because Roma's voice is so like warm and close in his podcasts, maybe he's doing something specific and technical to the files to achieve that? That would be my actual guess. It's like there's something about the actual kind of file. The way that Roman is converting his podcast to an MP3, that's just like too complicated for Ben's car system. And I was thinking about it and I was like,
所以我不知道。本认为，因为罗曼的声音在他的播客中非常温暖和亲近，也许他对这些文件做了一些具体的技术处理来达到这种效果？这其实是我的猜测。就好像实际文件种类有什么问题一样。罗曼将他的播客转换为MP3的方式，对本的车载系统来说太复杂了。我想了一下，然后我觉得，
these are the two constants in his problem. One is the podcast, it's always the same podcast. And the other is that it's always the same radio. I was like, maybe just that's like a bad radio. But even if it's a bad radio, it's still interesting because like why is this radio bad only with their numbers invisible? Not only that, but we got another email
这是他问题中的两个常数。一个是播客，总是同一个播客。另一个是总是有同一个收音机。我想，也许这只是个烂收音机。但即使它是个烂收音机，它仍然很有趣，因为为什么这个收音机只有在播放他们的隐形节目时才不好用？不仅如此，我们还收到了另一封电子邮件
from another person experiencing exactly the same problem with exactly the same podcast. That is so weird. Um, all right, so I have to figure this out. Okay, cool. Hello. How you doing? I'm good. How you doing? I'm good. It is a pleasure to hear your voice, not on the podcast. Yes. Yeah, I'm me as well. I was very delighted to get your email. Are you totally in the darkest of why I would reach out to you? Totally. So I told Roman why I was calling him.
来自另一个人，他遇到了完全相同的问题，听着完全相同的播客。这太奇怪了。嗯，好吧，所以我必须弄清楚这一点。好的，酷。你好。你好吗？我很好。你呢？我也很好。很高兴听到你的声音，不是在播客里。是的。是的，我也是。收到你的电子邮件我非常高兴。你完全不知道我为什么会联系你吗？完全不知道。所以我告诉罗曼我为什么要打电话给他。
And I told him about what was going on with Ben's car. There's one that causes his car stereo to freeze, shut down, and restart. And Roman had actually heard about this problem from other listeners. Yeah, I don't know what it is. We got some details for it a few times from a few different people, but I've never really figured it out. All Roman knows is that in some cars, Bluetooth plus car radio plus 99% invisible causes everything to break, but he has no idea why.
我告诉了他关于本的车发生的事情。有一个播客会导致他的车载音响死机、关闭并重启。罗曼其实从其他听众那里听说过这个问题。是的，我不知道这是怎么回事。我们从几个不同的人那里听到过几次关于它的细节，但我从来没有真正弄清楚过。罗曼只知道，在某些汽车里，蓝牙加上车载收音机再加上《99%隐形》会导致一切崩溃，但他完全不知道为什么。
So I ran Ben's theory by him. He's like, well, Roman obviously cares about the sort of texture of the sound. Maybe he's doing something very specific to his files. And I'm curious like, what is your setup like? Do you have a strange microphone of some kind? No, I mean, we have a couple, I use like a shotgun mic in the studio. But you're not using some kind of special encoding settings that are different from the rest of radiotopia. No. No. Roman said that he had a theory that he's actually pretty confident about, which is the thing that makes his podcast unusual is that it uses the percent sign.
所以我把本的理论告诉了他。他说，嗯，罗曼显然关心声音的质感。也许他对他的文件做了非常具体的操作。我很好奇，你的设置是什么样的？你用的是某种奇怪的麦克风吗？不，我的意思是，我们有几个，我在录音室里用那种枪式麦克风。但你没有使用某种与其他广播乌托邦不同的特殊编码设置吗？没有。没有。罗曼说他有一个他非常有信心的理论，那就是他的播客不寻常的地方在于它使用了百分号。
The percent sign, as in the percent sign, 99% invisible? Yeah. Oh. He was like, it must just not play well with the stereo for some reason. So it's like, because the stereo can also display the name of the podcast, there's something about just there being a symbol where it doesn't expect there to be a symbol where it breaks.
百分号，就像百分号里的百分号，《99%隐形》？是的。哦。他说，出于某种原因，它一定就是和车载音响不太兼容。所以就像是，因为车载音响也可以显示播客的名字，所以在它不期望有符号的地方出现了一个符号，这就导致了崩溃。
Yeah. And it really bums Roman out honestly. He's been hearing about it for years from other people who are not been, but like what can you do about it? He's not going to change the name of the podcast. You know, like, I would love it to be fixed, and I really, if somebody's a fan on the show,
是的。老实说，这真的让罗曼很难过。他多年来一直从其他不是本的听众那里听到这件事，但你能对此做些什么呢？他又不会去改播客的名字。你知道，就像，我很希望它能被修复，而且真的，如果有人是这个节目的粉丝，
I really hate for them not to be able to hear it. Like, I wish it could be better, but I think I recognize the futility of me fighting it, I think, is the thing. I feel like a primary fundamental tenet super tech support is realizing that something is futile and well outside of our capability and putting on a football helmet and running headfirst into it anyway.
我真的很讨厌他们听不到。就像，我希望情况能更好，但我认为我意识到了我与之抗争的徒劳无功，我想这就是问题所在。我觉得超级技术支持的一个核心基本原则就是意识到某件事是徒劳的，并且远远超出了我们的能力范围，然后戴上橄榄球头盔，依然一头扎进去。
Well, I mean, if you solve it, I would be really grateful. It's just like when it just seemed like there's this is one of those things where all these technologies are budding up against each other. where all these technologies are budding up against each other. And I am, is some little bit of grit that gets caught between the gears of, you know, tech companies, you know, not knowing how to pass things off and talk to each other. That's what I feel like I am. The irony of this was crazy making. 99% visible. A podcast dedicated to explaining the beauty of good design, that is the one podcast that breaks when you try and play it on Ben's Masta. It just felt like an imbalance in the universe that I had to correct. And Roman's theory about the percent sign, it felt really plausible to me, so I thought
好吧，我的意思是，如果你解决了它，我会非常感激的。这就像是所有这些技术相互碰撞的时候。所有这些技术都在相互碰撞。而我，是夹在科技公司齿轮之间的一点点沙砾，你知道，他们不知道如何传递信息和互相交流。这就是我感觉自己扮演的角色。这种事的讽刺意味简直让人抓狂。《99%隐形》。一个致力于解释优秀设计之美的播客，却成了当你试图在本的马自达上播放时唯一崩溃的播客。这感觉就像宇宙失衡，我必须纠正它。罗曼关于百分号的理论，对我来说听起来真的很合理，所以我认为
I'd start there. And I figured like, if the percent sign is given the car trouble because it's a special character, other special characters should break the car too, so I just wanted to test that theory. Basically you're thinking like classic tech support problem, like you have to replicate the glitch to understand it, to solve it. Exactly. So I started thinking about other special characters, like, you know, what about like the carrot,
我应该从那里开始。我想像，如果百分号给汽车带来了麻烦，因为它是一个特殊字符，其他特殊字符也应该让汽车崩溃，所以我只想验证那个理论。基本上你的想法就像是经典的技术支持问题，就像你必须复制故障才能理解它、解决它。完全正确。所以我开始考虑其他特殊字符，比如，你知道，像脱字符，
or the curly brackets, or whatever. The curly brackets? You know, the curly brackets. Oh, yeah, yeah. Next to the P. Yeah, they look like they'd be music notation. Okay. So we wanted to make a podcast that would break hysteria. And to do that, we devised a test.
还是大括号，诸如此类的。大括号？你知道的，大括号。哦，对，对。在P键旁边。是的，它们看起来像是音乐符号。好的。所以我们想做一个会使音响崩溃的播客。为了做到这一点，我们设计了一个测试。
Uh-huh. who's we? Me? Most of the team to be honest. Okay. It was me, Tim, Anna, Fia, Emanuel, Shruthi, Domiano. I was about to make funny you guys because I was like, oh, why does it take that many people to make a podcast?
嗯哼。谁是“我们”？我？说实话，大部分团队。好的。是我、蒂姆、安娜、菲亚、埃马纽埃尔、施鲁蒂、多米亚诺。我正要开你们的玩笑，因为我在想，哦，为什么制作一个播客需要这么多人？
It was like literally because I made people to make this podcast. So why wouldn't it? Also, we didn't make one podcast. How many podcasts did you make? Well, let's just start at the beginning. Okay. So the first podcast we made is called
字面意思就是因为我需要人来制作这个播客。那为什么不呢？另外，我们制作的不止一个播客。你们制作了多少个播客？好吧，让我们从头开始。好的。所以我们制作的第一个播客叫做
Carrot Space Carrot. You know the carrot, which is the little pointy upwards arrow. Yeah. Okay, it's called Carrot Space Carrot. Whose job was it to make the podcast art? I was mine. Okay. That was pretty nice. It's like a child's drawing of like a bug's called carrot space carrot. Mm-hmm. Who's job was it to make the podcast art? I was mine. Okay. That's pretty nice. It's like a child's drawing of like a bug's bunny carrot and then in the background
胡萝卜太空胡萝卜。你知道脱字符吧，就是那个小向上的箭头。是的。好的，它叫胡萝卜太空胡萝卜。制作播客封面是谁的工作？是我的。好的。那挺不错的。这就像是小孩子画的一只兔八哥的胡萝卜，然后在背景中
There's a planet. Oh, I get it. It's like carrots and space. I'm just gonna play it for you. Okay God we are in Alex Coleman territory. That's synth. Hello, welcome to the Carrot Space Carrot. Pops. Pops. Pops. I recorded this in my attic. I feel like this is the ASMR that like, printers listen to when they're trying to go to sleep the night.
有一个星球。哦，我明白了。就像胡萝卜在太空中。我这就放给你听。好的，天啊，我们进入了亚历克斯·戈尔曼的领域。那个合成器。你好，欢迎来到胡萝卜太空胡萝卜。流行音乐。流行音乐。流行音乐。我在阁楼里录制的这个。我觉得这就是打印机在试图入睡时听的ASMR。
The atomic red carrot has slimeless... ...the travel forward. Three times. You're describing what? The atomic red carrot? I hate times produces darkest corrupted or queen-hands-lakes. Don't you just feel like relaxed? No, I don't feel relaxed. How do you feel?
原子红胡萝卜没有史莱姆……向前移动。三次。你在描述什么？原子红胡萝卜？我讨厌时代产生最黑暗的损坏或安妮女王蕾丝。难道你不觉得放松吗？不，我不觉得放松。你感觉怎么样？
I feel like a robot's trying to mug me. Like a robot's trying to hypnotize me to go to sleep so it can mug my data. Queen-hands-lakes. A niolates. Negative. Queen-hands-lakes. I think I've had enough this fight. Okay.
我觉得有个机器人正试图抢劫我。就像一个机器人正试图催眠我让我睡觉，这样它就可以抢劫我的数据。安妮女王蕾丝。消灭。负面的。安妮女王蕾丝。我想我对这个播客已经够了。好的。
I'm not going to be able to do that. I'm not going to be able to do that. I'm not going to hypnotize me to go to sleep so it can mug my data. Queen Anne's lace. A Nile Anne's. Negative. Queen Anne's lace. I think I've had enough of this podcast. Okay. So, we made this podcast. We uploaded it to podcast apps and to an RSS feed. Uh-huh.
我做不到。我做不到。催眠我让我睡觉，这样它就可以抢劫我的数据。安妮女王蕾丝。消灭。负面的。安妮女王蕾丝。我想我对这个播客已经够了。好吧。所以，我们制作了这个播客。我们把它上传到播客应用程序和RSS源。嗯哼。
We gave it to Ben. Uh-huh. And I asked him to try it in his car. Go ahead and listen. And we'll see if it breaks your car stereo. Alright, let's do it. And play. Hello. I'm the Kyrgyz speaker. Can you look at your screen and see how this is affecting your stereo.
我们把它交给了本。嗯哼。我让他去车里试试。继续听吧。我们会看看它是否会让你的车载音响崩溃。好吧，我们开始吧。播放。你好。我是基尔吉语发言人。你可以看一下屏幕，看看这会对你的音响有什么影响。
So I have to tell you, it is functioning completely normally. Interesting. It also means it's not filtering for the quality of podcasts. So then we wanted to make a podcast to test the less than symbol, the tilde, which is the symbol that means approximately, and the greater than symbol. Okay. I'm just going to play you the beginning.
所以不得不告诉你，它的运作完全正常。有趣。这也意味着它并没有对播客的质量进行过滤。所以接下来我们想要制作一个播客来测试小于号、波浪号（表示大约的符号）以及大于号。好的。我只放给你听开头。
Okay. That's John T. Hi, this is Samine Nasrat. Welcome to greater than less than approximately. You got Samine Nasrat to make your big podcast? Yes. Jesus. Samine wrote the book Salt Fat Asset Heat
好的。那是约翰·T。嗨，我是萨米娜·诺斯拉特。欢迎来到大于小于大约。你请到了萨米娜·诺斯拉特来制作你的大播客？是的。天哪。萨米娜写了那本书《盐、脂肪、酸、热》
and she also has a Netflix show by the same name. Such always sound and. Ha ha ha ha ha. Today I'm joined by a cooking newp, Alex Goldman. Hey, thanks for having me. Oh, I'm so glad you could be here. You got her to teach you cooking? I've been trying to learn cooking for a book for like a year.
她还有一个同名的网飞节目。听起来总是这样。哈哈哈哈哈。今天和我一起的是烹饪新手，亚历克斯·戈尔曼。嘿，谢谢邀请我。哦，我很高兴你能来。你请她教你做饭？我为了出一本书一直在学做饭，大概有一年了。
A berry clefote is basically a pancake with berries in it, but instead of being cooked on the stove, it's cooked in the oven. Okay. Do you feel like you're not with me today? I feel very excited for a Mazda. What you have to understand about this is this isn't your average cooking show, because the only way that you could give me instructions is by telling me the ingredients were less than approximately or greater than 8th.
浆果克拉福蒂基本上就是里面有浆果的煎饼，但不是在炉子上煮的，而是在烤箱里烤的。好的。你觉得你今天没有和我在一起吗？我为马自达感到非常兴奋。你必须明白的是，这不是你普通的烹饪节目，因为你给我指令的唯一方法是告诉我配料是小于大约还是大于第8个。
I hate my heart. It's just such waste. Less than approximately or greater than some other thing. So let me find an example here. The measurement for the sugar should be about, do you ever had one of those toys that you know, those stress balls? Uh, yes. Okay, you should put about a stress ball amount of sugar into the bowl.
我恨我的心。这太浪费了。小于大约或者大于其他什么东西。所以让我在里找个例子。糖的测量应该是大约，你玩过那种玩具吗，你知道的，那些解压球？呃，是的。好的，你应该把大约一个解压球分量的糖放进碗里。
So you're saying like greater than one of those super balls? This is great. Yes, greater than a super ball. So, just a black thing on the top. Okay. Okay. For the eggs, can you add an amount of eggs that's greater than the number of nipples you have?
所以你是说大于其中一个超级球？这太棒了。是的，大于一个超级球。所以，顶部只有一个黑色物体。好的。好的。对于鸡蛋，你能添加数量大于你乳头数量的鸡蛋吗？
So you're saying like less than the sides of a square. Correct. Anyway, the very clef who T I made as you might imagine didn't turn out good. Was not edible. Yeah. So did this break the Mazda? He popped it in his podcast player. Alright. Hi, this is Samine Nostrat? He popped it in his podcast player. All right.
所以你的意思是小于正方形的边。正确。不管怎样，正如你所想象的那样，我做的浆果克拉福蒂结果并不好。根本没法吃。是的。那么这破坏了马自达吗？他把它塞进他的播客播放器里。好吧。嗨，我是萨米娜·诺斯拉特？他把它塞进他的播客播放器里。好吧。
Hi, this is Samine Nostrat. Welcome to greater than less than approximately. It seems to be working just fine. Okay. So at this point, we have tried the carrot, the tilde, the less than sign, the greater than sign. We even made another podcast where we tested the plus sign, the equal sign, the curly brackets, none of them are replicating this problem. Have you ever had the thing happen where you go to get like an object repaired and the people in the repair shop
嗨，我是萨米娜·诺斯拉特。欢迎来到大于小于大约。它似乎运作得很好。好的。所以到目前为止，我们尝试了脱字符、波浪号、小于号、大于号。我们甚至制作了另一个播客来测试加号、等号、大括号，它们都没有复现这个问题。你有没有遇到过这种情况：你去修理某个东西，修理厂的人
care about the object differently than you care about it? Do you know what I mean? Like they're like, oh, what this guitar really needs is like to be a double neck guitar. And you're like, no, it doesn't. But then they're just like doing it and they're often doing it. You know what I was like to have more of a relationship
关心的东西和你关心的东西不一样？你知道我的意思吗？就像他们会说，“哦，这把吉他真正需要的是做成一把双颈吉他。”而你会说，“不，它不需要。”但然后他们还是去做了，而且经常去做。你知道我指的是那种
to the work they want to do than to helping you. I don't know what you're talking about. Yeah, I mean either okay But of course at this point we were definitely gonna test the percent sign right right so I would argue you could have just started by testing the percent sign some wood some wood argue You seem to just want to make a bunch of garbage podcasts. How dare you call these garbage? So we made a podcast that was called 100% Related. Hi, my name is Alex Goldman and you're listening to 100% Related? The premise of this is a couple days ago I was talking to our editor Tim Howard and he insisted that I was only 50% Related to my dad because I only have 50% of my dad's genes.
对他们想做的工作的关心超过了对帮你的关心。我不知道你在说什么。好吧，我也一样，好吧。但当然，在这个时候我们绝对要测试百分号，对吧？对吧？所以我可以说，你本可以从测试百分号开始的。有人会这么说。你好像只想制作一堆垃圾播客。你怎么敢把这些叫作垃圾？所以我们制作了一个播客，叫做《100%相关》。嗨，我的名字叫亚历克斯·戈尔曼，你正在收听《100%相关》？这个节目的前提是几天前我和我们的编辑蒂姆·霍华德聊天，他坚称我和我爸爸只有50%相关，因为我只有我爸爸50%的基因。
Hello. Father. So you're 50% related to your dad and you're 50% related to your mom? I'm 100. My opinion is I'm 100% related to both of my parents. But in Tim's worldview. Yes. And so what we did is we got my dad who, a former judge,
你好。父亲。所以你和你爸爸50%相关，和你妈妈50%相关？我是100%。我的观点是我和我的父母双方都100%相关。但在蒂姆的世界观里。是的。所以我们做的是，我请了我爸爸——一位前法官——
to adjudicate this argument. What should I call you? Should I call you Judge Goldman? Or should I call you... I call you... Mark. Mark. Okay, he seems very biased in this, but whatever.
来裁决这个争论。我应该怎么称呼你？我应该叫你戈尔曼法官吗？还是我应该叫你……我叫你……马克。马克。好吧，他对此似乎很不公正，但随便吧。
Now, I'd like for you to lay out your case to him because what you're saying is insane. Well, it really just seems to me that if you were 100% related, you would be Mark. And you are not. You're 50% related. So, okay. What all are that?
现在，我希望你向他陈述你的理由，因为你所说的话简直太疯狂了。嗯，在我看来，如果你是100%相关的，你就是马克。但你不是。你们是50%相关的。所以，好吧。到底是什么？
What all are that? I'm 100% related to anyone who's my relative. So you are as related to your father as any other human being. That's what you're saying. Being Tim are on the same page. Spoiler alert, so was my dad. Oh Tim, was your dad took Tim's side?
到底是什么？我和任何作为我亲戚的人都是100%相关的。所以你和你父亲的相关性就像和其他任何人一样。这就是你说的意思。蒂姆和我的想法是一致的。剧透一下，我爸爸也是。哦，蒂姆，你爸爸站在蒂姆那边？
Yes. Good man. So, why is this the podcast? I like, because I like arguing with you. It's like for fans of arguing with you. Yeah. Oh, I don't feel good. So, the percent sign we love. Oh right, there's a point this.
是的。好样的。所以，为什么这是个播客？我喜欢，因为我喜欢和你争论。这就像是为喜欢和你争论的粉丝准备的。是的。哦，我感觉不好。所以，我们喜欢百分号。哦对了，这有个重点。
There's a point to this. He listened to the thing. I feel like I've fallen into your vortex. So clearly we were wrong about all the special characters breaking the radio which surprised me, but I just wanted to confirm the one thing that we were actually confident was true, which was that the percent sign would break the radio. So I give Ben the podcast. All right, let's do it. All right.
这有一个重点。他听了那个。我觉得我掉进了你的漩涡里。所以很明显，我们关于所有特殊字符都会让收音机崩溃的猜想是错的，这让我很吃惊，但我只是想证实一件事，那是我们真正确信为真的事，那就是百分号会破坏收音机。所以我把播客交给了本。好吧，我们开始吧。好吧。
So I give Ben the podcast. Alright, let's do it. Alright. Hello. I have to know, is it freezing your... Stereo. Alex, I'm really sorry to say. No. It is totally normal.
所以我把播客交给了本。好吧，我们开始吧。好吧。你好。我必须知道，它是不是让你的……音响死机了。亚历克斯，我很遗憾地告诉你。没有。它完全正常。
But how is that... How is that possible? So clearly, this caught me off guard. So Roman's whole theory that you found so obvious does not seem to be found it. It doesn't seem to be found it. And so at this point, I just start thinking that it has to be something within the file itself
但怎么会这样……这怎么可能？显然，这让我猝不及防。所以罗曼的整个理论——你觉得那么明显的理论——似乎并不成立。它似乎并不成立。所以在这个时候，我开始觉得一定是文件本身内部有什么问题
that they are uploading that's busted, that it doesn't actually have anything to do with the percent sign. Interesting. But then Ben tells us something that, again, bufffuttles us. Okay. Which is Ben found a copy of a 99% visible episode on YouTube and tried playing that over his car stereo.
他们上传的东西坏了，实际上和百分号没有任何关系。有趣。但随后本告诉我们一件事，再次把我们给整糊涂了。好的。那就是本在YouTube上找到了《99%隐形》某期节目的副本，并试图通过他的车载音响播放。
So he was like, I'm gonna see if Pirated 99 PI works? Yeah. And it breaks the car. It breaks the car? I mean, it breaks the stereo. It does the same thing. Yeah. Which is weird because it just means like,
所以他是想看看盗版的99 PI能否播放？是的。结果车机崩溃了。车机崩溃了？我的意思是，音响崩溃了。它做了同样的事情。是的。这很奇怪，因为这意味着
it's not actually anything about the file itself because when someone's uploading a podcast to YouTube, that's like a totally new file. Yes. It's like the content. It's like the car is sentient and doesn't like Roman Mars. And so Ben was like, the only option is that
实际上和文件本身没有任何关系，因为当有人将播客上传到YouTube时，那完全是一个新文件。是的。这就像是内容的问题。就好像这辆车是有生命的，而且不喜欢罗曼·马尔斯。所以本就觉得，唯一的可能就是
there must be some sonic frequency that is breaking the car. And I was like, there's like a note in Roman's voice that if you were just sitting in a Mazda and started talking to you loud, the car would just explode. That's wild. Also when I was a kid,
一定有什么声波频率在破坏这辆车。我觉得就像罗曼的声音里有一个音符，如果你正坐在马自达里，他对你大声说话，车就会直接爆炸。这太疯狂了。还有，当我还是个孩子的时候，
there's a rumor that there was one note that would make you poop your pants. Oh, yeah, the brown note. Yeah, I'm very familiar. Is that, that's not real. I don't think it's, we both know that's not real. But I don't read about it though, it's not real, but I'm glad you brought it up.
有一个传言说有一个音符能让你拉裤子。哦，对，那个“棕色音符”。是的，我很熟悉。那是，那不是真的。我不认为它是，我们俩都知道那不是真的。但我还是读了关于它的文章，虽然它不是真的，但我很高兴你把它提出来了。
Okay, I've been thinking about it this whole time. I could hear you think about it. I've been thinking about it this whole time. I could hear you think about it. I've been thinking about it since this story began. And I've been like, I'm in mixed company, I can't bring this up. I can't really do stuff yourself from saying something one time. Do you think Roman would think about it?
好吧，我一直在想这个。我能听出来你在想它。我一直在想这个。我能听出来你在想它。自从这个故事开始以来，我就一直在想它。我一直在想，我身处公共场合，我不能把这个提出来。你有时真的控制不住自己不说出来。你觉得罗曼会想到这个吗？
Do you think everybody was thinking about it the whole time? Brown note? Yeah, I hope so. Okay. So we're like, okay, we have no idea. We're like totally back to square one. You got to find the brown note. Oh boy. Oh boy. And the other reason this doesn't make any sense is because Roman has another podcast about Trump and the Constitutional
你觉得大家从头到尾都在想这个吗？棕色音符？是的，我希望如此。好吧。所以我们觉得，好吧，我们毫无头绪。我们完全回到了原点。你得找到那个棕色音符。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。这件事说不通的另一个原因是罗曼还有另一个关于特朗普和宪法的播客
law. Yeah, it's called what Trump can teach us about con law. And what happens without it? It plays a fine. Romans voice doesn't break the radio on that podcast only when it's 99% visible. Huh. So what happened? You called John Mazda. We call the company that makes the radio.
法律。是的，叫做《特朗普能教我们什么宪法》。结果怎么样？播放得很正常。在这个播客里罗曼的声音不会让收音机崩溃，只有在《99%隐形》里才会。哈。那么发生了什么？你给马自达打了电话。我们给制造收音机的公司打了电话。
We call Benz Mazda dealer. We are specifically dealing with a Mazda tech problem from a person who's in your service area and I was wondering if I could ask you a question or two about it. They weren't familiar with the issue. So we called Andrew Cooke-Louitts, the CTO of PRX, the public radio exchange. Hello, this is Andrew. Hi, Andrew, this is Alex Goldman. How you doing? Oh, hey, Alex, how are you?
我们给本的马自达经销商打了电话。我们专门处理来自你们服务区域内某人的马自达技术问题，我想问你们一两个关于它的问题。他们对这个问题并不熟悉。所以我们给PRX（公共广播交换中心）的首席技术官安德鲁·库克洛维茨打了电话。你好，我是安德鲁。嗨，安德鲁，我是亚历克斯·戈尔曼。你好吗？哦，嘿，亚历克斯，你好吗？
I'm good. He's in charge of how the show gets uploaded to podcast apps and our SS feeds. So you're just calling everybody being like, have you heard of this? Yeah. And Andrew said that he'd heard of it and that he'd always figured like Roman that it was the percent sign, but I told him about the test that we'd done. And all of them worked, including 100% related. No. Oh yeah.
我很好。他负责节目的上传方式，如何上传到播客应用程序和RSS源。所以你只是给每个人打电话，问：你听说过这个吗？是的。安德鲁说他听说过，他一直和罗曼一样觉得是百分号，但我把我们做过的测试告诉了他。所有测试都成功了，包括《100%相关》。不。哦，是的。
Crap. That's... Oh, he's like so painful, these kind of bugs. No one knew what was going on. And then... I want to solve this ahead of you. So did Ben. He actually got back in touch with us and said, hey, I've been running some tests on my own.
糟糕。那是……哦，这种bug真是太折磨人了。没有人知道是怎么回事。然后……我想在你之前解决这个问题。本也是。他 실제로 和我们取得了联系，说：“嘿，我自己进行了一些测试。
I tried uploading a couple podcasts. And what I found is that it's not the percent sign alone that is causing this issue. It is the percent sign followed by an uppercase I that shuts down the radio. Lowercase I, it doesn't? uppercase I, it shuts down. That's all we know. We don't know why.
我尝试上传几个播客。我发现并不是单独的百分号导致了这个问题。是百分号后面紧跟一个大写字母I才会导致音响关闭。小写字母I就不会？大写字母I就会关闭。这就是我们所知道的全部。我们不知道为什么。
uppercase I, your card doesn't fly. Lowercase I, podcast in the sky. You's all we know. We don't know why. Uppercase i, your card doesn't fly. Lowercase i podcast in the sky. You're a great guy. That's exactly right. So, I mean, I, so we're getting closer. And then you know our pal Kurt Melby who works again. Works again, what works again. I play Fortnite with most weekends. Who does coding at the office?
大写字母i，你的车飞不起来。小写字母i，播客飞上天。这就是我们所知道的全部。我们不知道为什么。大写字母i，你的车飞不起来。小写字母i，播客飞上天。你是个好人。完全正确。所以，我的意思是，I，所以我们越来越接近真相了。然后你知道我们的老朋友库特·梅尔比，他又在工作了。又在工作了，什么又在工作了。我几乎每个周末都和他一起玩《堡垒之夜》。是谁在办公室写代码的？
Yeah. He had an idea. Kurt. Alex. Thank you for coming into the studio today., he had an idea. Kurt. Alex. Thank you for coming into the studio today. Thank you, glad to be here. So the reason that we have you here is because you're the person who actually uploaded the podcasts that we made.
是的。他有个主意。库特。亚历克斯。谢谢你今天来到录音室。，他有个主意。库特。亚历克斯。谢谢你今天来到录音室。谢谢，很高兴来到这里。所以我们请你来的原因是因为你实际上是制作并上传我们制作的播客的那个人。
Yeah, that was fun. I don't know if you know this, but none of them worked. I listened to them also, and they were pretty entertaining. But yeah, I know I'm not surprised that that didn't work. All right, smart guy. Kurt says I have a theory. And the theory is that in the programming language C, uh-huh.
是的，那挺好玩的。我不知道你知不知道，但它们没有一个成功的。我也听了它们，它们还挺有趣的。不过，是的，我知道它们没成功，我一点也不觉得意外。好吧，聪明人。库特说我有一个理论。这个理论是，在C语言编程语言中，嗯哼。
Oh, I know what it is. I know what happened. Literally 99% means something. It means turn off your stereo in the programming language, see. You're close, but not exactly. In the programming language, see, basically in some scenarios, the percent sign means, hey, the character immediately following me,
哦，我知道是什么了。我知道发生什么了。字面意思，99%在C语言编程中意味着某些东西。这意味着关闭你的车载音响。你很接近了，但并不完全是。在C语言编程中，基本上在某些场景下，百分号意味着，嘿，紧跟在我后面的字符，
the character immediately following the percent sign, think about that like code rather than like text. And start parsing that as though it's asking you to run commands. And there's a thing called printf in C that's like used very, very commonly and heavily. Another language is to copy this feature to interpolate is the technical term interpolate the number into the string. And he said percent i in c is a command, whereas percent r, which would be 100% related, question mark, is not. So like, what's the command?
百分号后面的那个字符，要把它当作代码而不是文本来思考。并开始解析它，就好像它在要求你运行命令一样。在C语言中有一个叫做printf的东西，被非常、非常频繁和大量地使用。其他语言也复制了这个功能来内插——内插是将数字插入字符串的技术术语。他说C语言中的percent i是一个命令，而像“100%相关”问号里的percent r则不是。所以，命令是什么？
What is percent i tell a computer to do? So I have it up here. It has to do with, basically, the percent in c has to do with displaying integers, NC, I know, this is very confusing. Oh, my brain's mad at that. Yeah, I know. So, percent and then a bunch of different letters tell it to display integers in a certain way.
percent i告诉计算机做什么？所以我把它调出来了。它与……基本上，C语言中的percent与在C语言中显示整数有关，我知道，这非常令人困惑。哦，我的大脑对这个感到抓狂。是的，我知道。所以，percent加上一堆不同的字母告诉它以某种方式显示整数。
But basically what's happening, it sounds like, is the car stereo, it gets what it thinks is an audio file, what is an audio file, what is an audio file, and it's like, okay, this part of the information I have is just for the humans. This is like the title to display. Yeah, 99, and then there's, and then it's like, okay, now here's some stuff for you, the robots to understand.
但基本上发生的事情，听起来像是，车载音响收到了它认为是音频文件的东西，什么是音频文件，什么是音频文件，然后它就想，好吧，我拥有的这部分信息只给人类看。这就像是要显示的标题。是的，99，然后有，然后它就想，好吧，现在这里有些东西需要你们机器人来理解。
And it gets a bunch of gobbling guck and it gets confused and it shuts down. Yes. Wow. So there's a bunch of different commands and see that would cause this to happen. Okay. And so, we were like, okay, if Kurt's right, we should be able to test this with other
然后它收到了一堆乱码，接着它就糊涂了，然后关机了。是的。哇。所以C语言中有一堆不同的命令会导致这种情况发生。好的。所以，我们当时想，好吧，如果库特是对的，我们应该能够用其他
commands and those should also mess up the car stereo. And so, we made one more podcast. I don't know. Okay. With another one of the recognized pieces of syntax, which is the letter P, which when it follows the percent sign becomes the pointer address, whatever that means. Okay, but whatever, as long as it's going to code,
命令来测试这一点，那些命令也应该弄乱车载音响。于是，我们又制作了一个播客。我不知道。好的。使用了另一个已识别的语法片段，即字母P，当它跟随百分号时变成指针地址，不管这意味着什么。好的，但不管怎样，只要它会变成代码，
it should shut down the stereo, and that's what's happening. So we made a podcast that's called 88% parentheticals. Uh-huh. Here you go. This is Sarah Canig. And you're listening to 80% parentheticals. So wrong. I'm going to tell you about this document I'd been waiting for.
它应该会关闭音响，而这就是正在发生的事情。所以我们制作了一个名为《88%括号》的播客。嗯哼。给你。这是萨拉·科尼格。你正在收听的是《80%括号》。太离谱了。我要告诉你关于我一直在等待的这份文件。
It was one piece of paper that was going to change everything I thought I understood it now. It arrived on a Monday. Monday began like a normal day. I was walking to work with my dog, his name is Bruno by the way. He didn't come with that name. I named him Bruno.
这是一张纸，它将改变我对它的一切理解。它在一个星期一到达。星期一像平常一样开始了。我和我的狗一起散步去上班，顺便说一句，它的名字叫布鲁诺。它来的时候不叫这个名字。我给它取名叫布鲁诺。
He's a rescue dog. He came with the name like Bradley or something, which I really didn't like. So I changed it to Bruno, which by the way is the name I also wanted to name my son, but my head. We're in a parenthetical, I understand. I understand what you've done.
它是一只救助犬。它来的时候名字叫布莱德利什么的，我真的很不喜欢。所以我把它改成了布鲁诺，顺便说一句，这也是我本来想给我儿子起的名字，但是我的头。我们陷入了一个括号里，我明白了。我明白你做了什么。
With Bruno. And we get there. It's a short walk, like maybe 10 minutes, which is crazy because people are always like, what podcast do you listen to, what podcast do you listen to because you make podcasts and I'm like, not that many because I have such a short walk to work. Anyway, I get to my-
带着布鲁诺。我们到了。这是一段很短的步行，大概10分钟，这很疯狂，因为人们总是问，你听什么播客，你听什么播客，因为你制作播客，而我会说，没听多少，因为我上班走的路太短了。不管怎样，我到了我的——
I just was just wrong. Okay, I've heard enough. Okay, I don't want to live in a world where you can take up star-cating time with this. Also, there's like people that are like, oh, when's the next season of serial coming out? Like 20 minutes later than it would have. So what happened? Well, we sent it to Ben and it didn't break the car stereo. What? It didn't break it. So that screws up the whole theory. Absolutely. I mean, we didn't just try percent P.
我刚才——刚才搞错了。好吧，我听够了。好吧，我不想生活在一个你可以用这个来占用星际追踪时间的世界里。另外，还有人问，哦，《连环杀手》下一季什么时候出？比它原本应该出的时间晚了大约20分钟。所以怎么回事？嗯，我们把它发给了本，它没有让车载音响崩溃。什么？它没有崩溃。那把整个理论都搞砸了。完全是。我的意思是，我们不只是尝试了percent P。
We tried a bunch of different things that should have broken the car stereo in the same way that percent I does. And none of them caused a problem. So what then is Kurt's theory bunk? Kurt's theory appears not to work. The only combination that did anything was percent followed by an uppercase I. Okay, but we don't know why. No, we don't. And it is driving me nuts.
我们尝试了许多不同的东西，这些东西本应该以和percent i相同的方式让车载音响崩溃。但没有一个引起问题。那么，库特的理论是胡扯吗？库特的理论似乎不管用。唯一产生任何效果的组合是percent后面跟一个大写字母I。好吧，但我们不知道为什么。不，我们不知道。这让我快要疯了。
And this is the point in the story where Andrew Ku Klowitz comes to the rescue. Andrew Ku Klowitz? Remember, he's the CTO at Public Radio Exchange, the company that distributes 99% visible. Uh-huh. He really dove. Like, he really invested himself in this. What does that mean they really invested himself in it? Well, you know, we were trying to figure out a way
而这就是故事中安德鲁·库克洛维茨前来救场的时刻。安德鲁·库克洛维茨？记住，他是公共广播交换中心的首席技术官，该公司负责分发《99%隐形》。嗯哼。他真的深入研究了。我是说，他真的全身心投入到这件事情中了。这意味著他真的全身心投入到这件事情中是什么意思？嗯，你知道，我们当时在试图找到一种方法
to diagnose this properly without actually having access to the code. And you've done everything you could. You made a bunch of nonsense podcasts for no reason. Did you talk to somebody who worked at a Mazda dealership and one guy at work? We also called Mazda. Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha. Uh-huh. a Mazda dealership and one guy at work. We also called Mazda. Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha one of the original authors of the original code, which he then gave to us. The author of the code for the Moss Carstereo program?
在没有实际访问代码的情况下正确诊断这个问题。你已经尽力了。你无缘无故地制作了一堆无厘头的播客。你跟在马自达 dealership 工作的人和一个工作小伙子聊过吗？我们还给马自达打了电话。哈哈哈哈。嗯哼。马自达 dealership 和一个工作小伙子聊过吗？我们还给马自达打了电话。哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈阿格哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈，不，你不能再这样下去了。”
Yes. Wow. His name is Brandon Goosman. And is it embarrassing that I don't know, that I didn't already know that you can look in code and see the code's author? Like I didn't know that. There's a way to write your authorship in your code, and it's been done forever.
是的。哇。他的名字叫布兰登·古斯曼（Brandon Goosman）。我不晓得——我之前竟然不知道你可以通过查看代码来找到代码的作者，这会很尴尬吗？就像我以前不知道那样。有一种方法可以在代码中写下你的署名，而且这种做法一直都有。
And is it always like that, like a signature on a painting? It's a little, a lot of times it's harder to find, you have to have access to the code to see the authorship. Yeah. And my favorite story about this is early in the development of Atari games, Atari would not allow the author of the game to put their name on it. Because they're just being a company about it?
而且它总是那样吗，就像画作上的签名一样？有点像，很多时候它更难找到，你必须能够访问代码才能看到署名。是的。我关于这个最喜欢的故事是，在雅达利（Atari）游戏开发的早期，雅达利不允许游戏作者在上面署名。因为他们只是摆出一副大公司的架子？
Yeah, and so the author of the game adventure created this incredibly arcane set of things that you had to do in the game so that you would find a secret room that just flashed his name in the center of the screen. That's brilliant, AnSAD. It's like it's just sad that they had to go to that much work to just be like, I made this. Anyway, so you got in touch with Brandon.
是的，游戏冒险的作者在游戏中设计了一套极其晦涩难懂的操作，你必须完成这些操作才能找到一个秘密房间，房间正中央会闪烁他的名字。这太绝了，AnSAD。这简直有点可悲，他们得做这么多工作，只为了说一句“这我做的”。不管怎样，你联系上了布兰登。
Yes, he works on exercise technology now. I work for a company called Shapelog. We develop connected strength products. As a person who's terrible at exercising, I'm not your target audience. Yeah, the irony is the entire office of us working on this are not either. We're more like, stay up late and sit at our computer longer
是的，他现在从事运动科技工作。我在一家叫Shapelog的公司工作。我们开发联网的力量训练产品。作为一个极度讨厌运动的人，我可不是你们的目标受众。哈哈，讽刺的是，我们整个办公室负责这项目的人其实也都不喜欢运动。我们更像是那种熬夜到很晚、
people. So we told Brandon what was going on with Ben's car and he told us that he was pretty sure he knew what was going on. Which is. So what he said was... One thing that got my eye immediately is that there's a percent symbol in the name and that has some special meanings in things like a URL. Right. In a URL, certain characters are allowed and certain characters are not. So our operating theory was that percent I was breaking the radio because the
坐在电脑前更久的人。所以我们把本的车出现的问题告诉了布兰登，他说他大概知道是怎么回事。也就是……他说的意思是……我立刻注意到的一点是，名字里有一个百分号符号，这在URL等东西里有一些特殊的含义。没错。在URL中，某些字符是允许的，某些字符是不允许的。所以我们的推论是，百分号I弄坏了收音机，因为
percent sign followed by the letter I meant something in the programming language C. But what Brandon told us was no, that program wasn't even written in C. It was written in a totally different programming language C. But what Brandon told us was, no, that program wasn't even written in C. It was written in a totally different programming language. Okay. And to the radio, the percent I doesn't actually mean anything. And what Brandon thinks the problem is, is that the code should tell the radio to ignore things that it doesn't understand or that don't mean anything. But in this case, for whatever reason, it's not.
百分号后面跟着字母I在C语言编程中有着某种含义。但布兰登告诉我们，不是这样的，那个程序甚至根本不是用C语言编写的。它是用一种完全不同的编程语言编写的。好吧。对于收音机来说，百分号I其实没有任何意义。布兰登认为问题所在，是代码应该告诉收音机忽略它听不懂或没有意义的东西。但在这种情况下，不管出于什么原因，它并没有这样做。
So the radio sees percent I and just keeps desperately trying to figure out what it means. So it's like it's having a panic attack. Kind of. It's like I percent, percent I, percent I, percent I, percent I. And so then I was like, okay, so why is the stereo restarting? And Brandon told me that when they designed the car, they made it so that the radio was regularly sending a little message to the rest of the car saying, I'm working, I'm working, I'm working. Brandon called it a heartbeat. The hardware layer is listening for that. As long as it gets it, it's happy. If it doesn't
所以收音机看到了百分号I，就拼命地想要弄清楚它是什么意思。这就好像它在恐慌发作一样。有点像。它就像在说“百分号I，百分号I，百分号I，百分号I，百分号I”。然后我就想，好吧，那为什么立体声音响会重启呢？布兰登告诉我，他们在设计这款车时，让收音机定期向汽车的其他部分发送一个小消息，说“我正在工作，我正在工作，我正在工作”。布兰登称之为心跳。硬件层一直在监听这个消息。只要能收到，它就很开心。如果收不到
get it, it will assume that the UI has frozen and it will restart it to a known good state. It's saying it's not communicating with me. Something is wrong and it just starts over. So if it freezes up, then it doesn't send the hard beat. It is trained to automatically shut down and start back up. So that is why the computer is that's why it has a panic attack and then it takes an app and it wakes up and tries again. I really like how much effort we've put into
收不到的话，它就会假设用户界面已经死机，并将其重启到一个已知的良好状态。它等于是在说“它不跟我通信了。出问题了”，然后就重新开始。因此，如果它死机了，就不会发送心跳。它被设定为会自动关闭并重新启动。这就是为什么计算机会——这就是为什么它会恐慌发作，然后喝杯咖啡醒来，再试一次。我很喜欢我们在这上面花费了这么大劲，
personifying these cars. I just understand that they're sentient. I feel like this doesn't actually go against my original theory. Like everybody else, they freak out when they don't have the right answer. Right. There is one other thing that was suggested to us several times along the way.
把这些汽车拟人化。我只是觉得它们是有知觉的。我觉得这其实并不违背我的最初理论。就像其他人一样，当他们没有正确的答案时，他们就会抓狂。没错。在这一路上，还有另一件事被多次提到了。
Ben's car stereo firmware is a few other versions of it. So the theory is that if you updated the firmware, it might fix this problem. According to Masa, it will. But Ben looked into getting his firmware updated, and it was just too expensive for him. However, that doesn't mean that we don't have a more permanent solution for Ben and Roman. Because Andrew Cook-Louis from PRX had a very sweet idea.
本的车载音响固件还有其他几个版本。所以推论是，如果你更新了固件，可能会解决这个问题。根据马萨的说法，确实会的。但本研究了升级固件的费用，发现对她来说太贵了。然而，这并不意味着我们没有为本和罗曼找到一个更持久的解决方案。因为来自PRX的安德鲁·库克-路易斯（Andrew Cook-Louis）有一个非常甜蜜的主意。
Maybe we got to publish a version of 99% invisible with some slightly different titles or something. I'd be willing to create the Mazda version of the feed. That would be great. That would be super cool. There's just like a 99% invisible for Ben and other Mazda owners feed. Well, I can say that people in Nissan
也许我们得发布一个稍微不同标题之类的《99%无形》版本。我愿意创建马扎版本的订阅源。那太棒了。那会非常酷。这就好像有一个专门为本和其他马扎车主准备的《99%无形》订阅源。嗯，我可以这么说，日产的用户
have also reported having this problem, but yes, for Mazda owners and Nissan owners who are having problems with the specific infotainment system. That is a very niche podcast. So I called Ben up one more time. Just let me know if uh if uh when you got it set up and ready to roll. Well dude this is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Wars. Tim Hartford is a master at picking out the perfect little story.
也报告过遇到这个问题，不过是的，对于那些特定车载信息娱乐系统遇到问题的马扎和日产车主来说。那真是一个非常小众的播客。所以我最后给本打了一通电话。如果有进展，或者你准备好了随时告诉我。好吧，老兄，这就是《99%无形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。蒂姆·哈特福德（Tim Hartford）非常擅长挑选完美的小故事。
And everything's working fine? Economic principles. Yep, so this totally works. It's plain normally, not freezing at all. It's perfect. We'll have a link to the Mazda Safe 99PI feed on our website. After the break, we'll feature three full episodes of the fake podcasts from this story. I think that they played the full episodes. It would have disrupted their story too much, but they are gems. And I really want to play them for you. After this. And now, 88% parentheticals 100% related and greater than, less than, approximately,
而且一切都运行正常？经济学原理。是的，这完全行得通。它正常播放，一点也没有卡顿。太完美了。我们将在我们的网站上提供马扎安全版99PI订阅源的链接。休息过后，我们将为您带来本期故事中虚假播客的三期完整剧集。我想如果他们播放了完整的剧集，会过多地打乱他们的故事节奏，但它们确实是瑰宝。我真的很想放给你们听。广告之后见。现在，是88%的插话和100%的相关内容，大于、小于、大约，
in their entirety. This is Sarah Canig, and you're listening to 88% parentheticals. I'm going to tell you about this document I'd been waiting for. This one piece of paper that was going to change everything I thought I understood up to now. It arrived on a Monday. Monday began like a normal day. I was walking to work with my dog, his name is Bruno by the way. He didn't come with that name.
原汁原味。我是莎拉·凯尼格（Sarah Koenig），你收听的是《88%的插话》。我要跟你讲讲这份我一直在等待的文件。这唯一的一张纸，将改变我迄今为止以为自己理解的一切。它在一个星期一送达。星期一像平常一样开始了。我正带着我的狗去上班，顺便说一下，它的名字叫布鲁诺。它来的时候不叫这个名字。
I named him Bruno. He's a rescue dog. He came with a name like Bradley or something, which I really didn't like. So I changed it to Bruno, which by the way is the name I also wanted to name my son, but my husband nicks that. Anyway, I'm walking to work with Bruno and we get there. It's a short walk, like maybe 10 minutes, which is crazy because people are always like, what podcast you listen to, what podcast you listen to because you make podcasts. And I'm like, not many, because I have such a short walk to work. Anyway, so I like reach to unlock the door
我给他取名叫布鲁诺。它是一只救助犬。它来的时候名字叫布莱德雷之类的，我真的很不喜欢。所以我把它改成了布鲁诺，顺便说一下，这也是我本来想给我儿子起的名字，但被我丈夫否决了。不管怎样，我和布鲁诺正走去上班，然后我们到了。路程很短，大概10分钟左右，这很疯狂，因为人们总会问，你听什么播客，你听什么播客，因为你是做播客的。而我的回答是，没听多少，因为我上班走的路太短了。不管怎样，我伸手去开门
and I notice that at the bottom of the door there is this envelope with just my name on it, no return address, which I hate that. Why do people not put, I mean, I understand if you need to be anonymous, but just generally, like I always teach my kids, like put your return address on the envelope in case it gets lost.
我注意到在门底下有这样一个信封，上面只写了我的名字，没有回信地址，我最讨厌这样了。为什么人们不写——我的意思是，如果你需要匿名我能理解，但一般来说，就像我总是教导我的孩子们那样，在信封上写上你的回信地址，以防信件丢失。
Anyway, and one time I did get this crazy anonymous letter, which is a whole other story I can tell you about another time. Anyway, so I open this envelope with just my name on it, and inside is a single document, which I'll tell you about next time. This episode of 88% parentheticals was produced by a manual Jochi. Our editor is Tim Howard, music in case you're wondering about the music, is by the mysterious breakmaster cylinder. You can check us out online or so I've been told I've never checked myself.
不管怎样，有一次我确实收到了一封疯狂的匿名信，那是另一个故事了，我改天可以讲给你听。不管怎样，我打开了这个只写了我名字的信封，里面只有一份文件，我下次再告诉你关于它的事。这一期的《88%的插话》由伊曼纽尔·约基（Emmanuel Dzodzi）制作。我们的剪辑师是蒂姆·霍华德（Tim Howard），音乐——如果你对音乐好奇的话——是由神秘的刹车大师西林（Breakmaster Cylinder）创作的。你可以在网上查看我们的节目，或者别人是这么告诉我的，我自己从来没查过。
On iTunes or wherever you get your podcasts. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ Hi, my name is Alex Golden and you're listening to 100% related? A podcast about family. Alright, let's start the show. Hello. Father. Son. Hello, I'm recording you right now in the interest of full disclosure. All right, you have my permission. Thank you.
在iTunes或你获取播客的任何地方。[♪ 片尾音乐播放 [♪ 嗨，我叫亚历克斯·戈尔登（Alex Golden），你收听的是《100%相关》吗？一个关于家庭的播客。好了，我们开始节目吧。你好。父亲。你好，为了完全坦诚起见，我现在正在录音。好吧，我同意。谢谢你。
I'm in the studio with Tim Howard, our editor. Hi. How are you? Tim, how you doing? Doing wonderful. Thank you. What should I call you? Should I call you Judge Goldman or should I call you?
我和我们的剪辑师蒂姆·霍华德在录音室里。嗨。你好吗？蒂姆，最近怎么样？好极了。谢谢。我该怎么称呼你？我该叫你戈尔登法官，还是应该叫你……
I call you. I call you. I call you. Mark, all right. Good to meet you, Mark. What should I call you? You should call me Judge or should I call you coming mark mark alright good to meet mark what should I call you you should call me just both but i love it so we are actually calling upon you in your capacity as a judge we we're having a disagreement and uh... we would like you to hear both sides and adjudicate if that's possible
我叫你。我叫你。我叫你。马克，好吧。很高兴见到你，马克。我应该叫你什么？你应该叫我法官，还是应该叫你“马克马克，好吧，很高兴见到马克，我应该叫你什么？你应该叫我都可以，但我喜欢这样。所以我们其实是请你以法官的身份来评判。我们之间产生了分歧，呃……我们希望你能倾听双方的陈述并做出裁决，如果可以的话
alright we'll go first is the plaintiff uh... that's it i'd say that team is the plaintiff i you're the one with the complaint, Tim? Tim came to me yesterday with a bold proposition that I profoundly disagreed with and I want to, yeah, okay, so I'll just tell you what it was. It's just simply that for some reason, Alex and I, I don't even know how we got on the topic,
好吧，我们先听原告的……呃……就这样吧，我说蒂姆是原告。我——你是那个有意见的人，蒂姆？蒂姆昨天带着一个让我深以为然的大胆提议来找我，我深表不赞同，我想，好吧，那我直接说是什么事吧。很简单，不知为什么，我和亚历克斯——我都不知道我们是怎么聊到这个话题的，
but I argue to Alex that he and you are 50% related. And I said that we are 100% related. Now, I'd like for you to lay out your case, Tim, because what you're saying is insane. Well, it really just seems to me that if you were 100% related, you would be Mark. And you are not. You're 50% related. So, okay. What I'm saying is like, when you're related to someone, you're 100% related to the regardless of how many genes you share.
但我向亚历克斯辩称，他和你是50%的相关。我说我们是100%相关。现在，我想请你陈述一下你的理由，蒂姆，因为你的说法太疯狂了。好吧，在我看来，如果你是100%相关，那你就是马克了。但你不是。你是50%相关。所以，好吧。我的意思是，当你们有亲戚关系时，无论你们分享多少基因，你们都100%相关。
Look, I have like a second cousin twice removed, you know, who like my aunt's grandson, my cousin's kid. Uh huh. I'm still 100% related to that person. I'm 100% related to anyone who's my relative. So you are as related to your father as any other human being. That's what you're saying.
看，我有一个远房表亲，你知道的，比如我阿姨的孙子，我表弟的孩子。嗯哼。我和那个人依然是100%相关的。任何与我有亲戚关系的人，我都与他100%相关。所以你跟你父亲的亲缘关系和其他任何人都是一样的。这就是你的意思。
That you cannot be more related or less related to anybody well this feels like a like more like a less like a math argument and more like a semantic argument i mean i don't know but you i'm just i'm just following your your your logic here my logic is you can have a closer relationship to someone in that also higher percentage objection judge objection a picture of the argument uh... that all you got
即你和任何人的亲缘关系都不能更近或更远。嗯，这感觉更像是一个——与其说是数学争论，不如说是语义争论。我的意思是，我不知道，但我只是——我只是顺着你的逻辑在走。我的逻辑是，你和某人的关系可以更亲密，也就是百分比更高。反对，法官大人，反对。反驳这个观点……这就是你的全部论点吗？
what are you talking about it's makes perfect sense what i'm saying no but we're not done with the idea that you just said that you can be called more closely related but it's not a percentage no no what is it an on off okay But is that a percentage no no what is it on off okay all right let me let me let me let me ask a question okay so I did a genetic testing right about four or five years ago this doesn't sound good for me one of the big companies and you know about once every three or four months I get this notice from the company that says we have found more relatives of yours.
你在说什么呢？我说的话完全说得通。不，我们还没讨论完你刚才说的你可以被称为“关系更紧密”但它不是一个百分比的观点。不，不，那是什么？一个“开/关”状态吗？好吧。但是，那是一个百分比吗？不，不，那是什么？一个“开/关”状态吗？好吧。好吧，让我——让我——让我——让我问个问题。好吧，所以我做了基因检测，大概在四五年前。这听起来对我可不是什么好兆头。其中一家大公司，你知道，大概每三四个月我就会收到这家公司的一条通知，上面写着：“我们发现了你的更多亲戚。”
And these relatives of mine that are finding have like less than 1% of my genetic makeup. But this company, which is 23 and me, still consider these people to be relatives. Although I've never heard their name, I don't know who they are, but you know, they'll say point 0.65% genetic identity. All right. So here's the question. And I as related to them as I'm related to you. fuck you! You get arrested at that point in court, don't you? Yeah, it's contempt of court. Contempt of court. I'm going to go for my whole life. I'm going to go for it.
而这些被找到的我的亲戚，跟我分享的基因不到1%.但这家公司，也就是23andMe，仍然认为这些人是亲戚。虽然我从未听过他们的名字，也不知道他们是谁，但你知道，他们会说“0.65%的基因相同度”。好吧。所以问题是，我和他们的亲缘关系，和我跟你的亲缘关系是一样的吗？去你的！你到那一步就要在法庭上被捕了，对吧？对，这是藐视法庭。藐视法庭。我要坐一辈子牢。我要进去了。
Alright, well thank you so much Mark. Thanks Dad. Alright, Jim, I enjoyed it Alex. Mike is always talking. Yeah, same to you. I'll talk to you later. All right, take care. Bye. Bye-bye.
好吧，非常感谢你，马克。谢谢爸爸。好吧，蒂姆，我挺喜欢亚历克斯的。迈克一直在说话。对，彼此彼此。我们回头聊。好吧，保重。再见。再见。
Thanks for listening to 100% Related. You heard today from me, Alex Goldman, Tim Howard, and my dad, Mark Goldman. The show was produced by a manual Jochi. Our theme song is by the mysterious breakmasterman. The show was produced by a manual Hi, this is Samine Nasrat. Welcome to greater than or less than approximately. Today I'm joined by a cooking newbie, Alex Goldman. Hey, thanks for having me. Oh, I'm so glad you could be here. We're going to make a berry klafuti. What is a berry klafuti?
感谢收听《100% Related》。今天你听到的是我、亚历克斯·戈德曼、蒂姆·霍华德以及我父亲马克·戈德曼的声音。本节目由 Manual Jochi 制作。我们的主题曲出自神秘的 Breakmasterman。本节目由 Manual 制作。嗨，我是萨米娜·纳斯拉特。欢迎收看《多于或少于大约》。今天和我一起的是烹饪新手亚历克斯·戈德曼。嘿，谢谢邀请我来。哦，很高兴你能来。我们要做一个浆果克拉福提。什么是浆果克拉福提？
A berry klafuti is basically a pancake with berries in it, but instead of being cooked on the stove, it's cooked in the oven. Okay. Do you feel like you can do that with me today? I feel very excited to try. Okay, are you in your kitchen? I am in my kitchen. I've got that much down.
浆果克拉福提基本上就是里面有浆果的煎饼，但它不是在炉子上煮的，而是在烤箱里烤的。好的。你觉得今天能跟我一起做吗？我感到非常兴奋想试试。好的，你在厨房里吗？我在厨房里。我已经做到这一步了。
Okay, good. That's the right room to be in. All right. Let's make sure you have all of your ingredients. We need milk. Do you have milk? Got it. Okay, good.
好的，很好。待在正确的房间里。好了。让我们确保你所有的材料都备齐了。我们需要牛奶。你有牛奶吗？有了。好的，很好。
Do you have sugar? Yes. And eggs? Yes. Vanilla. We need some salt. I have salt. And then you need some flour. Mm-hmm, got it.
你有糖吗？有。还有鸡蛋？有。香草。我们需要一些盐。我有盐。然后你需要一些面粉。嗯，有了。
And do you have any berries around? I have some blueberries. Oh, perfect. Blueberries are great. Okay. Okay, the first step to making this is that we need to turn on the oven. So you have to heat your oven to a temperature that's a little bit less than the number of days in a year. Okay.
你周围有任何浆果吗？我有一些蓝莓。哦，太完美了。蓝莓太棒了。好的。好的，做这个的第一步是我们需要打开烤箱。所以你必须把烤箱加热到一个稍微少于一年中天数的温度。好的。
So we're talking like the number of degrees in a circle roughly approximately, maybe a little bit less than that. Okay. All right. Okay. And then you have to imagine that you're going to bake this pancake in a dish. It could be any shape. It could be round or rectangular or like ovular, I guess would be a word. But it needs to be approximately the size of like a small pan pizza. Okay, let me take a look. Hold on. Okay, I think I've got it.
所以我们说的是像圆圈里的度数一样，大概差不多，也许比那个稍微少一点。好的。好了。好的。然后你必须想象你要在一个盘子里烤这个煎饼。它可以是任何形状。它可以是圆的、长方形的，或者像椭圆形的，我想这个词可以。但它的大小需要大约像一个小型平底披萨。好的，让我看看。等等。好的，我想我明白了。
Okay, great. So we're gonna need to measure out some milk. And basically, I want you to put the amount of milk that is like approximately, you know, like, like a small jar of mayonnaise, amount of milk. So like, smaller than a full ketchup bottle. Definitely less than a full ketchup bottle. Definitely less than a full ketchup bottle. Like a bottle of ketchup that has been used generously at your house.
好的，太棒了。所以我们需要量一些牛奶。基本上，我希望你放的牛奶量大约是，你知道的，就像一小罐蛋黄酱的牛奶量。所以就像比一整瓶番茄酱小。绝对比一整瓶番茄酱少。绝对比一整瓶番茄酱少。就像你家里慷慨使用过的那种番茄酱瓶。
And then we're going to put some sugar. The measurement for the sugar should be about, do you have you ever had one of those toys that you know those stress balls? Uh, yes. Okay, you should put about a stress ball amount of sugar into the bowl. So you're saying like greater than one of those super balls? Yes, greater than a super ball, but less than a soft ball. Okay. Okay. For the eggs, can you add an amount of eggs that's greater than the number of nipples you have?
然后我们要放一些糖。糖的份量应该是，你有过那种你懂的那种压力球玩具吗？呃，有。好的，你应该把大约一个压力球分量的糖放进碗里。所以你是说比其中一个超级球多？是的，比超级球多，但比垒球少。好的。好的。对于鸡蛋，你能加一个数量的鸡蛋，这个数量大于你身上的乳头数量吗？
First of all, it's very presumptuous of you to know how many nipples I have. Second of all, so you're saying like, less than the sides of a square. Correct. All right. Man, I feel like I was born to bake. I'm really good at this.
首先，你觉得你知道我有多少乳头，这太自以为是了。其次，你是说，少于正方形的边数？正确。好吧。天哪，我觉得我生来就是为了烘焙。我真的很擅长这个。
I mean, it looks really good. For vanilla, we're going to put last time the number of lights on a traffic light amount of glugs into the bowl. You got it. OK. I put some glugs in there. OK, great.
我的意思是，它看起来真的很不错。对于香草，我们要放最后一次红绿灯上的灯数的咕嘟数的量到碗里。你懂的。好的。我往里面倒了几咕嘟。好的，太棒了。
I want you to put more than twice the amount of planets in the solar system of grains of salt into the bowl. You got it. Done. Okay, when it comes to the flour, yeah. How big is your big child, Harvey?
我希望你把多于太阳系行星数量两倍的盐粒放进碗里。你懂的。完成了。好的，说到面粉，对。你的大孩子哈维有多大？
He is, I don't know how big he is. Is he bigger than like three basketball stacked up? Yes. All right, I basically I want to imagine the size of Harvey's foot. Okay. And could you do a little more flour than the size of Harvey's foot into the bowl?
他，我不知道他有多大。他比叠起来的三个篮球还大吗？是的。好吧，基本上我想象一下哈维脚的大小。好的。你能在碗里放比哈维脚的尺寸多一点的面粉吗？
A little more flour than the size of Harvey's foot. Now what you're gonna have to do is use your whisk to blend everything until it's really smooth and frothy. All right, it is looking pretty frothy. Okay, great. Now you're gonna pour enough batter to create a layer that's a little bit thicker than a piece of cardboard into the bottom of the dish. So it would be approximately two pieces of matzo stacked on top of each other?
比哈维脚的尺寸多一点的面粉。现在你要做的是用你的打蛋器把所有东西搅拌均匀，直到它变得非常顺滑起泡。好的，看起来确实挺起泡的。好的，太棒了。现在你要倒足够的面糊，在盘子底部形成一层比硬纸板稍微厚一点的层。所以大约是两片叠在一起的无酵饼？
That sounds right, approximately that. Oh my god, I'm so excited. Does it smell good in vanilla? Yes, it'm so excited. Does it smell good in vanilla? Yes, it does. Awesome. So I want you to turn one of the burners of your stove on until the flame is a little bit greater than a lighter, like a zippo lighter.
听起来对了，大约那样。哦天哪，我太兴奋了。闻起来有香草味吗？是的，我太兴奋了。闻起来有香草味吗？是的，有。太棒了。所以我希望你打开炉子上的一个燃烧器，直到火焰比打火机大一点，比如 Zippo 打火机。
Oh, okay. And then set the dish on top of there. You're gonna leave the dish on there for a little bit less than the time it takes to brush your teeth. And what you're looking for is that the batter begins to set in the bottom of the dish. You got it, you got it, all right, here we go.
哦，好的。然后把盘子放在上面。你要把盘子放在上面大约比刷牙时间少一点的时间。你要找的是面糊开始在盘子底部凝固。你懂的，你懂的，好吧，我们开始。
So once it's set, you can pull it off the burner. Uh-huh. And now you're gonna add the berries. Okay. Now we're gonna add another stress ball amount of sugar over the berries. Okay. And now you get to top it all off with the rest of the batter. Just sort of drizzle it all over.
所以一旦它凝固了，你就可以把它从燃烧器拿下来。嗯哼。现在你要加入浆果。好的。现在我们要在浆果上再撒上一份压力球分量的糖。好的。现在你可以在顶部撒上剩下的面糊。就把它细雨般淋在四周。
Okay. Now you can just throw it into the oven. For how long? It's gonna be in there for about half as long as a movie. So approximately as long as an episode of bones. Yes, I would say it's greater than the length of an episode of bones without the commercials and the length
好的。现在你可以把它扔进烤箱了。烤多久？它要在里面待大约一部电影一半的时间。所以大约跟一集《识骨寻踪》一样长。是的，我会说它比没有广告的一集《识骨寻踪》的长度要长，而且长度
of an episode of bones with the commercials. Somewhere in there. Oh, okay. God, I really miss bones. Noted. All right, it's in there. It's in there. It's in there.
有一集带广告的《识骨寻踪》那么长。介于两者之间。哦，好吧。天哪，我真的很想念《识骨寻踪》。记下了。好的，它在里面了。它在里面了。它在里面了。
Alex, are you gonna, who are you gonna eat this Klafu tea with? I'm probably gonna eat it with my wife and kids, which I'm super excited about, because my son loves dessert more than anything in the world. And your children, approximately how old are they? Harvey is older than a wheel of Parmesan?
亚历克斯，你要，你要和谁一起吃这个克拉福提？我可能会和我妻子和孩子一起吃，我对此超级兴奋，因为我儿子比世界上任何人都要热爱甜点。你的孩子们，大概多大了？哈维比一块帕尔马干酪还要老吗？
I don't know how old wheels of Parmesan are. A wheel of Parmesan is about as old as... It's a little bit less than the length of a typical American presidency one term. Oh no he's yeah he's greater than a wheel of Parmesan. on. Has it been approximately the number of minutes in a bones episode? Yes. I'm going to take the clef Uti. I'm going to show you what it looks like.
我不知道帕尔马干酪轮有多老。一块帕尔马干酪大概和……它比典型美国总统任期一届的时间稍微短一点。哦不，他，是的，他比一块帕尔马干酪老。它大约经过了一集《识骨寻踪》的分钟数了吗？是的。我要拿克拉福提。我要给你看看它长什么样。
It's literally just came out of the oven. Okay. I can't wait to see it. In its state now, I would say that it approximately looks like your local skate park. You know how there's like sort of like hills and valleys that are sort of oddly placed in order to maximize like grinding and jumping and leaping. That's I think what it looks like right now. The rising and the falling is a natural part of the process, so you've done that part, right?
它刚刚出炉。好的。我等不及要看了。就它现在的状态而言，我会说它看起来大约像你当地的滑板公园。你知道怎么会有那种奇怪放置的小山和山谷，为了最大化那种滑行和跳跃和飞跃。我想它现在就是那个样子的。起伏是这个过程的自然部分，所以你做对了这一部分，对吧？
I think you've done a great job. I'm really excited for what you've made. It's not a clafootie. It's closer to like a souffle pancake or a Dutch baby pancake. But unfortunately, it does look like it's less brown than the like golden deliciousness that I had hoped for. But I still think it will be delicious delicious and I think you should taste it. All right. I wish I were there. It's delicious. It's like eggy kind of.
我觉得你干得太棒了。我对你做出的东西感到非常兴奋。这不是克拉福提。它更像是一个舒芙蕾煎饼或荷兰宝芬煎饼。但不幸的是，它看起来确实比我希望的那种金黄色的美味要不够棕。但我仍然认为它会很美味，而且我认为你应该尝尝。好的。我希望我在那儿。它很好吃。有点像蛋饼那种。
Yeah, I feel like it's a success. All right. Simeon, thank you so much for having me on your show. I am so pleased that you were able to join me today, Alex. Oh my God. I feel greater than I did on the day I graduated high school. Oh, I feel greater than the day you graduated from high school, too. The show is hosted by Mee, Simeon Nasrat.
是的，我觉得这是一个成功。好的。西米恩，非常感谢你邀请我上你的节目。我很高兴你今天能加入我，亚历克斯。哦天哪。我觉得比我高中毕业那天感觉更棒。哦，我也觉得比你高中毕业那天感觉更棒。本节目由我、西米恩·纳斯拉特主持。
It's produced by Anna Foley, and our music is by Breakmaster Syllinder. Thanks so much for listening! These three podcasts and all the other podcasts that reply all made to test the Roman Mars Mazda Bug are available in your favorite podcast app, just search for them, or on the reply all website, which is linked in the show notes. Reply All is hosted by PJ Boat and Alex Goldman. I could not be a bigger fan of their show. Go listen to it. It is great. Produced by Shruti Panamanini, Via Benin, Damiano Marquetti, Anna Foley, Jessica Young, and a manual Jochi. Tim Howard is the editor mixing by Rick Kwan and Kate Balinsky, fact-checking by Michelle Harris. Their intern is Christina Ayelae DeJosa. Special thanks to Khalilaholt, Jim Fisher, Sidney Memeleus, Peter Olephant, Eli Manning, and Kurt Melby. And from my end, I'd like to give a special shout-out to Andrew Cook-Louitts, the CTO of
它由安娜·弗利制作，我们的音乐由 Breakmaster Cylinder 创作。非常感谢收听！这三个播客以及 reply all 为测试罗曼·马尔斯马自达 Bug 所做的所有其他播客都可以在你最喜欢的播客应用中找到，只需搜索它们，或者在 reply all 网站上找到，该网站链接在节目说明中。Reply All 由 PJ·沃特和亚历克斯·戈德曼主持。我再怎么是他们节目的粉丝也不为过。去听吧。它太棒了。由 Shruti Panamanini、Via Benin、达米亚诺·马尔凯蒂、安娜·弗利、杰西卡·杨和 Manual Jochi 制作。蒂姆·霍华德是剪辑师，混音由里克·关和凯特·巴林斯基完成，事实核查由米歇尔·哈里斯完成。他们的实习生是克里斯蒂娜·阿耶莱·德约萨。特别感谢卡利拉·霍尔特、吉姆·费舍尔、西德尼·梅梅利乌斯、彼得·奥利芬特、伊利·曼宁和库尔特·梅尔比。从我这方面来说，我要特别感谢安德鲁·库克-路伊茨，他是
PRX who created all those 99 PI dummy feeds for Alex and Benda Test. As evidenced here, Andrew always works above and beyond the call of duty. The reply all theme song is by the mysterious Break Master cylinder. The closing song is Simplicity by Macroform. Only Matt Lieber once, but he was very nice and very, very tall. 99% of his was a project of KALW 91.7 in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. We are a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative
PRX 的首席技术官，他为亚历克斯和本达测试创建了所有那些 99 PI 虚拟源。事实证明，安德鲁的工作总是超越职责要求。Reply All 的主题曲由神秘的 Break Master cylinder 创作。片尾曲是 Macroform 的《Simplicity》。马特·利伯只来过一次，但他非常友善而且非常非常高。他 99% 的节目是旧金山 KALW 91.7 的一个项目，在美丽加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的 Radio Row 制作。我们是 PRX 旗下 Radio Topia 的成员，这是一个由最具创新性的群体组成的激烈独立的集体
shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radtopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI Orc. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But we have links to 99PI and articles of interest feeds that do not break any car stereos at 99pi.org Radio Tapio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
播客中的所有节目。在 radtopia.fm 上找到它们。你可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与有关该程序的讨论。你可以在推特上 @我 Roman Mars 并 @该节目 99PI Orc。我们在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上也有。但我们在 99pi.org Radio Tapio 从 PRX 上有指向 99PI 和不破坏任何汽车音响的兴趣文章源的链接。本期节目尚无评论。点击转录中的任意句子发表评论。